[Musik]
Bock meine lieben Freunde und herzlich
willkommen heute zu einer neuen Episode
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 2 hier vorne
ist ja unsere sehr kleine aber trotzdem
sehr süße Küche unserer Hobbithöhle hier
vorne unser Schlafgemach mit dem süßen
Kamin mit dem Margeriten und dann hier
vorne der storage room also der
Lagerraum wo doch der braustand fehlt
den wir allerdings natürlich erst
bekommen können wenn wir dann wirklich
Lohn Routen erhalten haben die wir aber
auch erst im never uns besorgen können
heute soll es allerdings nicht um die
Hobbithöhle gehen meine lieben Freunde
sondern
ich habe
irgendein komisches Geräusch gehört ist
allerdings auch egal meine lieben
Freunde denn heute wollen wir uns gar
nicht von irgendetwas komischen ablenken
lassen von irgendwelchen Geräuschen von
irgendwelchen Monstern was auch immer
denn wir reparieren heute endlich unser
Dorf dorthin
ich höre die ganze Zeit Zombies
irgendwie zunächst aber laufe ich mal
hier zu unseren Kühen hin und fahre noch
mal zwei von denen denn zwei Weizen
hatte ich gerade noch im Inventar mehr
habe ich hier leider nicht drin ich muss
noch die ganzen Sachen noch mal
irgendwann alle dann in die Hobbit Höhle
reinpacken doch zuvor werde ich mich
erstmal auf die Reparatur vorbereiten
und dafür mein Inventar so ausleeren und
umräumen dass sich genügend Werkzeuge am
Start habe zunächst einmal machen wir
uns nämlich eine Schaufel dann noch eine
erneute Akt die hier ist ja schon fast
kaputt und dann wollte ich mir auch noch
eine neue Spitzhacke machen ich glaube
dass wir diese drei Utensilien auf jeden
Fall gebrauchen können ich kann nur
nachts schlafen es ist noch nicht ganz
Nacht von daher kann ich euch jetzt auch
erstmal ganz kurz zeigen was überhaupt
heute der Plan ist denn klar ich
repariere das Dorf allerdings werden wir
z.B das hier abtragen ich werde hier
vorne Stufen hinsetzen so dass wir einen
vernünftigen Weg haben die man
vernünftig Langlaufen muss damit man
nicht die ganze Zeit springen muss und
ihr seht ja auch schon das Dorf ist
ziemlich lange hier sind überall
irgendwelche komischen Sachen im Weg wie
irgendwelche Steinmauern und so weiter
und so fort die werden wir
selbstverständlich auch alle abreißen
nun ist es allerdings wirklich dunkel
von daher sprinten wir direkt hier rein
und gehen jetzt erstmal noch in unserem
ersten anfangshaus hier kurz schlafen
wir müssen auch demnächst irgendwann die
ganzen Items rüberbringen von diesem
Haus rüber in die Hobbithöhle zuvor
kümmern wir uns jetzt allerdings wie
bereits gesagt um unser Dorf deswegen
euch jetzt meine ganz kurze timeless wie
ich das hier ein bisschen Ebene
[Musik]
ich habe hier gerade alles so ein
bisschen sauber gemacht allerdings habe
ich das Gefühl dass meine tree Job bei
Modifikation nicht mehr funktioniert
und das ist nicht gerade vorteilhaft bei
solchen großen Bäumen von daher werde
ich die jetzt einfach mal so dumm stehen
lassen und mich dann zur nächsten
folgehin darum kümmern dass diese
Modifikation wieder funktioniert
allerdings habe ich bisher jetzt erstmal
hier den ganzen Weg so ein bisschen
sauber gemacht diese Blöcke hier bei
euch
das regt mich echt auf dass die immer
spawnen ne
wir müssen hier auf jeden Fall demnächst
noch mehr Bäume fällen
so Freunde ich habe den Weg jetzt mal
hier vorne so auslaufen lassen dann
läuft man hier so rein kommt hier dann
in das Dorf rein und hier ist der Weg
dann jetzt komplett gerade also wir
befinden sich keine Lagerfeuer mehr hier
drauf die standen hier rum oder
irgendwelche Steinmauern oder keine
Ahnung was hier weiß noch nicht so ganz
genau wie ich das machen soll weil hier
halt so eine Kurve lang läuft der hier
muss allerdings auf jeden Fall auch noch
weg und hier beim Brunnen überlege ich
mir ob ich den überhaupt mal komplett
weg mache weil der halt voll im Weg rum
steht hier in der Mitte ob man hier
einfach so ein Platz ist weil der Boden
ist eigentlich Todes unnötig da können
wir die Glocke auch einfach abbauen
jedoch werde ich mich jetzt erstmal
daran setzen mir noch ein paar
bruchsteinstufen zu holen so dass wir
die dann gleich da vorne als Wege
hinsetzen können ich befinde mich jetzt
allerdings auf der anderen Seite unseres
Dorfes und zwar habe ich hier den Weg
komplett abgebaut und mit Erde zugebaut
so dass es hier so ein bisschen
verwucherter aussieht und der Weg quasi
hier vorne endet deswegen wird er hier
einmal so rumgehen quasi zu dieser
komischen Städte kleinen Segen
Situationen hier und diese ganzen Sachen
die kann ich auch mal ganz kurz abbauen
ich will es halt wenn schon jetzt einmal
richtig machen so dass halt alles
perfekt aussieht also der hier noch Weg
der Weg und der Weg und hier auch noch
mal kurz Erde rein so dass wir hier
vorne dann quasi den Weg so um die Ecke
haben dann kann ich das hier auch kurz
abbauen bzw hier vorne auch einfach Erde
draufsetzen dann denkt man nämlich das
geht ja einfach um die Ecke rum das
ganze findet sich dann auch hier vorne
wieder weil ich halt will das alles
perfekt aussieht damit ich mich halt
auch wohlfühle ich weiß dass ich davon
das wird sich wahrscheinlich jeder gute
Minecraft spiele jetzt denken äh ich
profitiere davon nicht davon dass es
hier irgendwie jetzt schön aussieht hier
um die Kurve rum dann kann ich das
vielleicht auch sogar hier so ein
bisschen irgendwie noch so lange bauen
allerdings finde ich das ist für mich
einfach schöner aussieht die Blumen
setzt jetzt einfach mal hier in die Ecke
und dann wissen wir hier vorne geht der
Weg lang zu dieser Städte hin und hier
müssen wir dann den Weg auch ausbauen
und immer wenn es so ein bisschen höher
geht setzt sich da dann quasi
Steinstufen drauf damit es so ein
bisschen auch noch Wiedererkennungswert
hat von der ersten Staffel Minecraft mit
Luca die gehen allerdings alle schon
schlafen deswegen gehe ich auch mal ganz
kurz pennen und ein neuer Tag ist auch
schon angebrochen Freunde jetzt werde
ich den Weg hier einfach mal noch hier
vorne so ein bisschen weiter laufen hier
vorne dann die Stufen dran dann hier den
Weg wieder so ein bisschen weiter so
dass das Ganze in diesem Bereich dann
doch schon sehr clean aussieht die Sache
ist dann allerdings dass ich halt nicht
weiß wie ich es ab hier weitermachen
soll hier vorne geht's natürlich erstmal
hier runter und hier vorne dann kann ich
auch hier den Weg weiterlaufen lassen
und hier sieht wirklich sehr cool aus
der soll hier natürlich nicht stehen
allerdings habe ich das und das habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch gesehen dass sie
auch schon viel schöner gemacht mit der
mit dem Bergkeller Seite das kann man
vielleicht noch bis hierhin dann sogar
rüber ziehen das sieht dann schon sehr
sehr wild aus hier mit dem Berg die
Sache ist allerdings dass ich halt
wirklich nicht weiß wie ich das und das
kann ich auch mal erstmal hier vorne
noch weiter ziehen tatsächlich dass ich
das alles so ein bisschen künstlicher
schöner aussieht die Sache ist
allerdings nicht weiß wie das apropos
ich sage so häufig die Sache ist
allerdings
wurde mir auch in die Kommentare
geschrieben Alter ich muss echt mal
aufhören damit jedoch machen wir hier
jetzt erstmal ganz kurz weiter müssen
hier vorne alles erstmal so ein bisschen
wieder abbauen so dass es so aussieht
als ob der Weg wirklich nur da lang
läuft wo der Weg auch ist also hier drei
Steinstufen hin dann hier vorne mit der
Axt mit der Schaufel wieder drauf dass
sie wieder abbauen die Sache ist nun
allerdings dass wir uns jetzt um den äh
Brunnen kümmern müssen und ich bin
wirklich der Ansicht dass der Brunnen
weg muss ich werde ihn jetzt erstmal
stehen lassen ihr könnt ja mal jetzt
unten in die Kommentare schreiben ob ihr
denkt der Brunnen sollte hier bleiben
oder sollte abgebaut werden jetzt habe
ich allerdings auch keine Erde mehr und
werde dementsprechend jetzt erstmal ganz
kurz aus unserem Dorf hier raus laufen
irgendwo ein bisschen weiter weg um eine
und Leute trymacs hier
ich will einfach nur Erde abbauen
dieser Wald ist voller Gefahren ein paar
Sekunden später
ja ich habe gesagt der Wald ist voller
Gefahren ich habe jetzt mal fast zwei
Stacks Erde abgebaut die Sache ist
allerdings dass unser Dorf sicher so
weit ziehen das hatte ich gar nicht mehr
so richtig in erinnerung das ist
natürlich auch ein bisschen vorne
weitergeht mir geht's allerdings heute
erstmal um den wichtigsten Bereich und
zwar ist das unser Bereich da hinten und
hier vorne die Ausläufe die können wir
sonst noch mal jemand anders machen ich
bin natürlich auf eure Kommentare
angewiesen ob ihr wollt dass der Boden
stehen bleibt oder nicht schreibt mir
gerne mal unten in die Kommentare und
dann gucken wir mal ob wir den Boden
abreißen in der nächsten Folge oder
stehen lassen dass sie bei euch
allerdings trotzdem mal ganz kurz ab und
der Weg geht dann hier weiter das blöde
ist nur das ist es jetzt ab hier immer
so ein bisschen kniffliger wird auch mit
den Stufen weil das von einem dreierweg
dann irgendwie zu einem Vierer Weg
wieder wird also hier vorne geht's ja
irgendwie lang ich komme hier zwar so
hoch allerdings geht man dann hier so
komisch irgendwie runter deswegen werde
ich den Weg jetzt glaube ich einfach
hier so lang laufen lassen so dass er
quasi ab hier eine dreierbreite
weiterhin hat okay meine Schaufel ist
gerade kaputt gegangen allerdings dann
hier vorne zu so einer Vierer zweier
breite wieder in die Richtung ich mache
mir auf jeden Fall erstmal kurze neue
Schaufel und dann werde ich jetzt auch
erstmal hier vorne die Bäume Abfällen
okay guck mal die tree Chopper
Modifikation funktioniert bei solchen
Bäumen ich weiß allerdings nicht ob ich
irgendwas falsch gemacht habe bei den
anderen Bäumen gerade oder ob es jetzt
irgendwie daran liegt dass das
Tannenbäume waren weil hier funktioniert
alles perfekt das jetzt gerade nur
stehen geblieben weil hier vorne noch
was dran war aber das sollte jetzt auch
mit weggehen ja perfekt und das Ding
hier fällt sich auch komplett von
alleine also ich weiß nicht was ich da
hinten gerade falsch gemacht habe
allerdings ist der Bereiche jetzt
erstmal komplett leer ich weiß dass das
süß und schön aussah ich habe das auch
so ein bisschen Animal Crossing
irgendwie erinnert die Sache ist
allerdings dass ich hier erstmal alles
was ein Trampelpfad ist wegmachen wollte
und zwar zu Erde nur wenige Minuten
später ich habe keine Ahnung ob ich
gerade falsch denke allerdings könnte
ich doch theoretisch einfach ein
Wassereimer nehmen den hier draufsetzen
und das klappt nicht
dadurch sind jetzt nur meine
Johannisbeeren kaputt gegangen die
setzen wir ganz kurz wieder hin und
jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich jeden
einzelnen Block hier mal ganz kurz eben
abbauen und jetzt setzen wir in jeden
einzelnen oh schaut mal da hinten kann
man perfekt zu unserem Eingang von der
Hobbit Hülle gucken jetzt setzen auf
jeden Fall in jeder einzelne Lücke hier
wieder einen Erdblock rein so haben wir
jetzt auf jeden Fall alles hier
ausgekleistert die Sache ist dass das
jetzt natürlich wenn sich die ganze Zeit
hier angepasst haben und dann zu Gras
geworden sind dann sieht das natürlich
ein bisschen
steril aus sage ich mal sind dann aus
wie so ein Kunstrasen Fußballplatz das
wollen wir natürlich nicht allerdings
wollen wir das alles natürlich so ein
bisschen auf seine Symmetrie hat und
schön aussieht deswegen werde ich das
ganze hier jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen
anpassen an den Seiten und dann haben
wir schlussendlich hier einen Platz wo
man sagen kann hey guck mal der sieht
schön aus und der ist vor allem frei von
irgendwelchen Bäumen und Hindernissen
und irgendwelchen Monstern die das Bauen
können hier vorne werde ich dennoch noch
mal ganz kurz den Weg abbauen und den
auch durch Erde ersetzen so dass wir
dann wirklich irgendwie in der nächsten
oder übernächsten Folge wenn ihr alles
zu Gras verwandelt worden ist mal
schauen können wie wir den Weg von hier
rüber Systemhaus zu unserer Hobbithöhle
nach der ganz hinten führen können weil
da soll auf jeden Fall was cooles
irgendwie stattfinden hier vorne sieht
alles perfekt aus hier sieht es auch
sehr sehr schön aus es fehlen nur noch
so ein bisschen die Beleuchtungen da
kommen wir gleich zu allerdings sind wir
quasi mit dem Weg fertig bis zu dem
Brunnen hier vorne und es macht jetzt
wirklich keinen Sinn für mich hier
weiter alles irgendwie schön zu machen
wenn ich nicht weiß ob der Brunnen hier
weiter sein soll oder nicht deswegen
werde ich mich jetzt noch mal ganz fix
eben um die Beleuchtung hier kümmern
dann nehmen wir jetzt nämlich wieder
unsere eisenklumpen legen die hier im
Kreis und packen die Fackeln in die
Mitte so dass wir acht Laternen bekommen
und ihr seht auch schon hier unten ich
habe acht Bruchsteinmauern und auch acht
Laternen deswegen werde ich natürlich
das ganze genauso machen wie hier am
Eingang und auch beispielsweise hier
vorne mit den Laternen denn Laternen
sind einfach das geilste Leuchtmittel
minecraft was es gibt finde ich ich
werde erstmal hier vorne eine hinsetzen
an die Ecke das finde ich ganz schön
dann haben wir das hier auf jeden Fall
beleuchtet und hier vorne haben wir zwar
auch Beleuchtung ich finde allerdings
dass hier an die Ecke auch so ein Ding
auf jeden Fall hin muss zack dann können
wir hier vorne auch noch einen AdBlock
hinsetzen und das ganze so noch so ein
bisschen weiter hier rumführen um die
Ecke jetzt haben wir allerdings jetzt
nur hier vorne eine Beleuchtung und hier
sieht alles sehr dunkel aus ich muss
allerdings erstmal ganz kurz schlafen
gehen bevor ihr noch irgendwelche
Monsters bauen habe ich nämlich gar
keinen Bock auf das jetzt irgendwas von
unserem schönen neuen Weg hier irgendwie
in die Luft fliegt also machen wir
direkt weiter in einem neuen Tag und
schauen jetzt mal wo wir hier vorne
vielleicht noch ein bisschen Beleuchtung
hinsetzen können ich finde hier
meine Lieben
ich finde hier vorne sollte sich das
Wiederfinden weil das ja auch hier vorne
ist so eine kleine Laterne und dann
können wir das ganze auch hier vorne
machen wenn es hier runter geht
beziehungsweise würde ich vielleicht
hier auch eher hier oben hinsetzen einen
weiter zack da ist unser Eisengolem den
können wir theoretisch auch mal ein
bisschen heilen der beschützt ja unser
Dorf hier immer so ein bisschen zack das
freut ihn auf jeden Fall auch dann ist
es hier auf jeden Fall auch so ein
bisschen ausgeleuchtet und die letzte
Laterne setzen wir jetzt einfach mal
hier auf die Ecke auch mit einem Abstand
so jetzt weiß ich ja wie bereits gesagt
nicht was ich hier mit dem Brunnen
machen soll habe allerdings noch drei
Bruchsteinmauern und wir haben sogar
zwei Eisen geholfen okay krass
wahrscheinlich
meine Lieben
chillig wahrscheinlich weil unser Dorf
wirklich so groß ist also ich habe noch
nie so ein riesiges Minecraft
ich habe noch nie so ein riesiges
Minecraft Dorf erlebt allein wenn man
sich mal auf der Karte anschaut das ist
ja nur ein kleiner Teil davon das ist ja
wirklich krass geht ja noch zu der Seite
da vorne rüber und da hinten geht's ja
auch noch weiter ich werde jetzt
allerdings auf jeden Fall meine
Bruchsteinmauern nehmen und hier vorne
zum Eingang auf jeden Fall noch ein Teil
hinsetzen zack dass wir einfach wissen
hier geht's los dann noch hier vorne
eine Beleuchtung hier fehlen generell
noch die bruchsteinstufen da setzt sich
dann einfach mal hier beispielsweise
eine noch hin und dann können wir auch
hier vorne unsere bruchsteinstufen dran
setzen Bam Bam Bam und dann zum Beispiel
hier vorne noch eine Laterne dann haben
wir das auf jeden Fall auch fertig hier
können wir jetzt natürlich auch noch
demnächst Beleuchtung mit den allerdings
weiß ich halt wie bereits gesagt noch
nicht so richtig wie ich das machen soll
mit dem Weg ich werde war auch noch nie
hinten drin ich habe mir auch noch nie
so richtig die ganzen Kisten hier
angeschaut das können wir eigentlich
auch noch mal ganz kurz jetzt zum Ende
des heutigen Videos machen hier vorne
waren wir glaube ich schon dran genau da
haben wir ja als studieren die Sachen
rausgenommen hier vorne habe ich noch
was drin gelassen genau die
Fichtenstämme süß-bären fichtenschild
und ein bisschen Kartoffeln bzw Brote
hier vorne haben wir keine Kiste drin
das sieht cool aus als Sessel so mit dem
Fichten mit der fichtentreppe hier vorne
haben wir eine Kirche da haben wir einen
Kartenhersteller und hier oben haben wir
nur Brote Papiere und leere Karten drin
die können wir auf jeden Fall auch
beschriften dann demnächst du gehst mal
ganz kurz raus hier haben wir wieder ein
Schleifstein hier haben wir auch eine
Kiste drin mit Brot ich mache es einfach
mal ganz kurz mir so einfach und bau das
hier ab so dass ich die Kiste dann
einfach ganz easy hier wieder hinsetzen
kann so dann schauen wir noch mal ganz
kurz was wir hier haben es wäre
natürlich krass wenn wir irgendwas
heftiges hier drin hätten die haben wir
allerdings überall nahezu nur die
gleichen Sachen drin also Tour auch
wieder hin hier ist nur noch eine
Werkbank hier haben wir noch ein Gebäude
auch mit einer Kiste ich glaube oh wir
haben zwei Smaragde ich habe noch gar
keine Smaragd in Minecraft glaube ich
bekommen in diesem Projekt allerdings
schaue ich jetzt mal was ich
wegschmeißen kann Papier brauche ich
nicht und Kürbiskerne brauche ich auch
nicht Fichten Setzlinge habe ich genug
Weizen habe ich genug dann setze ich die
Kiste für ihn wieder hierhin und dann
schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz eben
weiter was wir hier haben hier ist auch
eine Kiste drin Alter was geht denn ab
wie viele verschiedene Sachen haben wir
denn hier am Start im Haus gegenüber
haben wir auch eine wusste darin
befinden sich Eisenbarren Gold ein Eisen
Harnisch eiserner roshanisch okay krass
was geht denn hier habe ich packt jetzt
einfach mal eine Kornblume rein und in
Kürbis um die Sachen immer so ein
bisschen auszutauschen gehen wir mal
weiter in die nächsten Gebäude ey ich
dass ich hier noch nicht drin war guck
mal wie viel Eisen und Gold hier alleine
drin war hier ist nur komplette Rüstung
am Start ich lass jetzt einfach mal
verrottetes Fleisch und tannenbaumstämme
hier drin die brauche ich ja wirklich
nicht hier unten haben wir auch noch ein
Gebäude ich glaube ich habe einen
wirklich noch nie ein Dorf in Minecraft
gesehen wo so viele Kisten am Start
waren hier ist keine Kiste keine Ahnung
warum jetzt keine drin ist allerdings
geht es hier auch nicht weiter das sieht
wirklich sehr zerrupft hier alles aus
also müssen wir dem jetzt alles noch ein
bisschen schöner machen wir haben sogar
mein Gott das fällt mir jetzt gerade
erst auf wir haben ja noch ein zweites
Stockwerk bei unserer dorfsituation hier
zwei Stunden später boah hier war sogar
Obsidian drin und noch eine neue
eisenspitzhacke ey dass ich mir dieses
Dorf nicht früher angeguckt habe die
haben so viele Sachen die wir hätten
gebrauchen können ne das ist allerdings
jetzt auch schon das letzte Gebäude und
hier befindet sich keine Kiste mehr drin
hier vorne war ja auch nichts und da
hinten sind glaube ich auch keine
weiteren Häuser mehr gewesen also das
hier ist die Ausbeute aus unserem Dorf
wir haben auf jeden Fall erstmal
genügend Rüstungen wir haben auch ein
paar Smaragde gefunden und noch Eisen
und Gold und wir haben es geschafft das
oh guck mal hier vorne ist sogar schon
fast alles zu Gras geworden also können
wir demnächste irgendwann an geilen Weg
noch überbauen da hinten runter und an
der Stelle würde ich allerdings die
heutige Episode Minecraft von Lukas
erstmal auch beenden wir haben so ein
bisschen unser Dorf hier repariert
schreibt mir wie bereits gesagt ja unten
in die Kommentare ob ich den Boden
stehen lassen soll und es tut mir auch
leid ich weiß ihr wollte mal das in die
mich nicht so viel entschuldige
allerdings tut mir leid dass ich heute
mich nur um das Dorf gekümmert habe und
jetzt nicht wirklich auf Kommentare
eingegangen bin oder wirklich
vorangekommen bin was das Projekt ich
besiege den Enderdrachen angeht was soll
ich in der nächsten Folge machen
schreibt es unten in die Kommentare wenn
euch das Video gefallen hat dann lass
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
da abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke wenn es euch gefallen hat es
tut mir sehr sehr leid dass ich ein
bisschen müde aussehe bin ich auch es
ist gerade 11:30 Uhr und ich nehme das
Video noch auf weil ich gerade am
vorproduzieren und wir sehen uns
allerdings morgen erstmal im neuen Video
wieder auf meinem Kanal tschüssi
[Musik]